good morning believe nation today's
message is you're nuts over to you John
Hope Bryant people say I'm nuts and and
that's a compliment because they said
that Steve Jobs was nuts
they said the Ted Turner was nuts they
said the Bill Gates was nuts
they said that my hero dr. Martin Luther
King jr. was nuts let me tell you what
I'll take it you have to be nuts to be
an entrepreneur think about what you're
doing you're going up you're waking up
every single day doing something that
most people don't do you're doing
something everybody wants to do but most
people don't do you're waking up you're
trying to change the status quo you're
trying to have a meaningful impact on
the world you're trying to create
something where a lot of the odds are
stacked against you you start a business
knowing that 80% plus of businesses fail
and yet you are out here doing it you're
not I would do more than just take it I
would do more than just accept that
people will think that I'm not I see it
as a badge of honor I see it as
something that I'm proud of I'm happy
when somebody calls me nuts
because I have the courage to go out and
chase my dreams and do something that I
believe in while you're too busy sitting
in your office
daydreaming instead of actually taking
action on it I was recently mentoring an
entrepreneur about a business that I'm
involved in and was talking about how
this is an important business for the
community there's important business for
my city and for my country and the
impact that I want to have and he said
do people ever look at you and say that
you're a little bit nuts and my response
is yeah all the time
I'm used to it and I love it and what
you find that happens and you actually
believe it if you actually believe in
your vision if you actually believe that
it can come true right you actually
believe in it it's not just words you
feel it to your core then over time the
people around you they will get infected
with the same virus that you have it'll
be like a fever and it'll spread and you
that ambition you need that creativity
you need that big drive we need that big
vision if you want to attract people to
a noble cause and have them motivated to
want to join this crazy mission of yours
otherwise you have an uninspired team
who was there just to collect a paycheck
so you are nuts and you should be proud
of it believe so the question today
today is I want to know who around you
has called you nuts
leave it in the comments below and I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso